THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" ON
A VERY BUSY FRIDAY NIGHT.
QUESTIONS AND A SENATE HEARING
ROOTED IN SCIENCE HAVE CRITICS
SMEARING SENATOR RAND PAUL AS
TRANSPHOBIC.
WELL, TONIGHT, HE IS HERE AND
WILL RESPOND.
AS HE STRUGGLES WITH THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE, JOE BIDEN SHINES OUT
FRENCH.
RAYMOND ARROYO TELLS US HOW IT
WENT IN FRIDAY’S FOLLIES.
NEXT, LOCKING DOWN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
AND THAT’S THE FOCUSED TONIGHT
"ANGLE"."
UNDER INCREASING PRESSURE TO
JUSTIFY THE OBSCENE ONGOING
LOCKDOWN OF THE U.S. CAPITOL
GROUNDS, DEMOCRATS TRIED TO
PAPER IT OVER THIS WEEK WITH THE
VAGUE WARNINGS ABOUT TELE- TO
TERRIBLE THINGS I CAN HAPPEN AT
THE HANDS OF TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
THE ACTING CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF
AND A PATHETIC ATTEMPT TO SHIFT
BLAME FROM THEIR INADEQUATE
PREPARATION CLAIMED YESTERDAY
THAT HE HAD BEEN BRIEFED ABOUT
TROUBLING INTELLIGENCE REPORTS.
>> MEMBERS OF THE MILITIA GROUPS
THAT WERE PRESENT ON JANUARY 6TH
STATED THEIR DESIRE THAT THEY
WANT TO BLOW UP THE CAPITOL
UNTIL AS MANY AS MEMBERS OF HIS
POSSIBLE ARE WITH THE DIRECT
NEXUS TO THE STATE OF THE UNION.
WE THINK IT’S PRUDENT THAT THE
CAPITOL POLICE MAINTAIN ITS
ENHANCED AND ROBUST SECURITY
POSTURE UNTIL WE ADDRESS THOSE
VULNERABILITIES GOING FORWARD.
>> Laura: TRANSLATION,
AGENCIES ONE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO KEEP THE GOVERNMENT AND
ACCESSIBLE TO PEOPLE WHO PAY THE
BILLS.
THIS WILL INCLUDE SYSTEMS AND
SURVEILLANCE TO MONITOR, TRACK,
AND HARASS LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS
AMERICANS.
THERE’S A REASON THOUGH SHOULD
NOT BE PUBLIC NOW, WE WANT TO
SEE THEM.
THREATS AGAINST THE CAPITOL,
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, CABINET
SECRETARIES.
THEY ARE NOTHING NEW, THEY’VE
BEEN AROUND SINCE I WORKED IN
GOVERNMENT.
BY THEIR AMORPHOUS REASONING,
ALL OF WASHINGTON -- FROM NOW
ON, SHOULD BE A MILITARY
ENCAMPMENT WHERE NO CITIZEN IS
ALLOWED TO GO WITHOUT SPECIAL
PAPERS, SPECIAL DINING, SPECIAL
PERMISSION.
BUT WE KNOW IT’S A CHARADE.
WHILE DEMOCRATS INSIST ON
SERIOUS FENCING AND BARRICADES
ALONG THEIR PLACE OF WORK,
THEY’RE THROWING UP OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND SO ANY OF
MIGRANTS, TERRORISTS WHO WANT TO
BORDER ESSENTIALLY WALK RIGHT
IN.
BUT AMERICANS, WHO WANT TO BRING
THEIR FAMILY TO VISIT THE
CAPITAL AND SPEAK WITH A
REPRESENTATIVE IS TREATED LIKE A
TERRORIST.
I WAS THINKING TODAY THAT’S THE
CONTINUED LOCKDOWN OF CAPITOL
HILL IS KIND OF LIKE THE COVID
LOCKDOWN WITH THE MOVING
GOALPOSTS, LACK OF ANY METRICS,
AND VAGUE WARNINGS ABOUT
POTENTIAL DANGER DOWN THE ROAD.
LAST SPRING, DR. BURKE ANTHOLOGY
REPEATED THE REFRAIN 15 DAYS TO
SLOW THE CURB BUT NOW IT’S
BASICALLY WE CAN’T OPEN UNTIL
THE VIRUS IS VANQUISHED
EVERYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
SEE THE CHANGE?
PELOSI AND SCHUMER DOING THE
SAME THING BY KEEPING THE FEAR
OF JANUARY 6TH ALLY TO
POLITICIZE THEIR GRIP ON POWER.
THEY’RE GETTING A BIG BOOST AS
WELL FROM THE BOOTLEGGERS IN THE
MEDIA.
SPEAK OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
CAN NO LONGER SAY THEY DON’T
AGREE WITH INSURRECTIONIST SCUM
OF THE BIGOTS, THE RACIST SCUM
OF WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
>> THE EXTREMIST GROUPS.
GROUPS AND EXTREMISTS.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT YOU.
ANY CONSERVATIVE FALLS INTO THE
CATEGORY WHERE THEY ARE
CONCERNED.
WE WERE TOLD THAT 26,000
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS WERE
NEEDED JUST TEMPORARILY TO KEEP
BIDEN’S INAUGURATION SIDE.
NOW, THEY ARE GOING TO SAY ALL
VULNERABILITIES ARE ADDRESSED
GOING FORWARD AS THE ACTING
CHIEF OF U.S. POLICE SAID.
THE BARRICADES AND THE TRUTH
WON’T BE REMOVED FROM
WASHINGTON, D.C., UNTIL
DEMOCRATS ARE VOTED OUT OF
OFFICE.
WHEN YOU CAN’T SAY THAT
"THE ANGLE" DIDN’T BORNEO.
I WORRY THAT THESE GATES AND
CEMENT BARRIERS, 12-FOOT FENCES
WILL NEVER GO AWAY.
THAT’S GOING TO BE THE "NEW
NORMAL."
ANY TIME YOU HEAR DEMOCRATS IN
THE ALLY CITING ONLINE CHATTER,
CAN JUSTIFY TAKING AWAY YOUR
FREEDOM AND SPENDING YOUR MONEY.
PIERCED BY THE SENSES SHOULD
KICK IN AT THIS POINT.
EVEN "THE WASHINGTON POST" HAD
BEEN FORCED TO CONCEDE THAT
TROUBLING ONLINE CONVERSATION
FAILS TO MATERIALIZE INTO A
TANGIBLE THREAT IN THE RUN-UP TO
BIDEN INAUGURATION, THE FBI ONE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT
THEY WERE POSING AS FAR LEFT
GUARD MEMBERS.
THEY TOOK AGGRESSIVE MEASURES TO
SECURE THE CAPITAL AND
ULTIMATELY COME IN DAY PASSED
WITHOUT INCIDENT.
ALL RIGHT.
THE TRUTH COMES OUT IN THE POST.
AGAIN, IF THE DEMOCRATS CARED
ABOUT THE SECURITY COME I REALLY
CARED ABOUT IT, THEY WOULD NOT
BE TRYING TO DISMANTLE ICE AND
PAUSE DEPORTATION FOR MONTHS ON
END.
BUT WHAT’S REALLY GALLING IS
THAT THE VERY PEOPLE WHO DIDN’T
READ OR ACT ON THE INTEL LEADING
UP TO JANUARY 6TH NOW WANT TO
INTERPRETEDINTERPRET IT.
>> WE KNOW THAT THEY WEREN’T
ONLY INTERESTED IN ATTACKING
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
OFFICERS.
THEY WANTED TO SEND A SYMBOLIC
MESSAGE TO THE NATION AND WHO
WAS IN CHARGE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
>> Laura: THERE’S A SYMBOLIC
MESSAGE OUT THERE ALL RIGHT AND
IS COMING FROM PELOSI AND
SCHUMER.
THE BARRICADES AND FENCES, THE
ASSAULT VEHICLES AND TROOPS,
THERE WHAT YOU COULD BE FACING
NEXT YEAR IF YOU ATTEND AN
ANTI-LOCKDOWN OR A PRO SECOND
AMENDMENT RALLY.
HE WILL BE THE NEXT SUSPECT IN
THE DOMESTIC TERROR DRAMA.
EVERY OPPORTUNITY, G.O.P.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS HAVE TO
START ASKING MEMBERS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WHETHER
THEY BELIEVE THAT CHINA OR TRUMP
IS A BIGGER THREAT TO AMERICA.
IS IT THE CCP OR THE G.O.P. AND
THE SUPPORTERS THAT WE SHOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT?
I DON’T KNOW, MAY BE
NANCY PELOSI ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
>> WE HAVE A DOMESTIC TERRORISM
CHALLENGE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHAT THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI TESTIFIED TO AT THE END
OF SEPTEMBER.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TAKING MORE
LIVES THAN INTERNATIONAL
VIOLENCE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THE LOGICAL FOLLOW
TO THAT IS THE BIGGEST TERROR
PROBLEM ARE ALL HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, WHY DO WE NEED SO